ce film parle d'une équipe aux
complications de l'amitié je ne peux pas
te protéger je suis un agent de terrain je connais
les risques plus que ça je suis ton
ami les gars sont sortis dans le
froid et Ethan est là-bas dans cette
croisade pouvez-vous trouver  lui
et le personnel jusqu'à ce que je traite, il ira dans
toute la mesure où nous avons essayé de sauver le monde
Benji est sur le terrain depuis un
moment expérimenté mais il n'est pas moins que
G oh hé les garçons quoi qu'Elsa soit un personnage très
puissant et mystérieux
Ethan lui fait confiance mais  l'équipe
remet en question sa croyance en sa justice
me tirer dessus ne fait pas d'elle une mauvaise personne
elle est une version féminine d'Ethan Hunt il
rencontre autant de son est de retour en tant
qu'analyste il était un peu en marge d'
être sur le terrain essayant de  éviter une
catastrophe Luther et Brandt
ne se connaissent vraiment pas très bien et
ne se font pas confiance v une seconde de
doute de quel côté
j'aime penser que ce personnage est tout simplement
incroyable de revoir les garçons, ils
étaient juste géniaux ce sens  o  f
camaraderie dans ce sens du chaos
c'est ce que vous ressentez quand vous le
regardez à Alec Baldwin et CIA
Alec est un antagoniste et une
menace certaine pour le FMI et une équipe alors que chéri
je ne sais pas que nous avons un grand méchant
avec Layne, il leur échappe constamment,
c'est réel, ils savent qui nous sommes, nous avons
une équipe incroyable, ils ont traversé
des choses ensemble et tout cela est
enveloppé dans les poursuites
et les explosions les plus excitantes et les combats, nous nous amusons beaucoup,
allez Angie  ouvre cette porte
toi